right now what I want to be looking at
is bundles partial differential
equations Fields operators Hilbert
spaces and I'm happy
to share what's going on with it I'm
happy to talk about what we I'm actually
not talking about you I'm not
criticizing you I'm saying that you want
to insulate scientists and give us the
academic freedom freedom that we were
promised and and I love talking to
people Brian but hold on let me finish
please sure I want to say I don't feel
like my other colleagues are engaging
with the public in a way that is uh is
going to further this project that
you're describing in other words they
said we sit in our in our offices or our
Laboratories and we just do what we're
supposed to we never talk to the public
we never communicate what we're doing
with their money and so of course why
should I give you more money you just
told me like I can't understand if I
could understand what you're doing it
wouldn't be worth a Nobel Prize right
Feynman uh so to what extent do we as
scientists have an obligation to have
portals of our own present company
excluded well you know you're doing I'm
doing it I'd rather be doing that stuff
but
um what stuff wait sorry you'd rather be
doing what
look
when I like to take a break from
actually doing research on something or
thinking about something or building
something or whatever it is I love
talking to people I'm a social person I
like explaining what I know
turning everything into interpersonal
drama or turning everything into a
market or turning everything into a game
theoretic exercise is killing
what we knew how to do even a short time
ago so I would love to do you know half
a day's worth of uh you know actual
research equations whatever
and then I'd like to record something
but if I'm going to record something I
just want to spill into a studio and I
want to tell somebody you know in a
week's time get these things worked up
as Graphics I don't want to think about
payroll I don't want to think about
human resources I don't want to think
about uh whether or not sponsors and
right well it's like I record in this
room with a lot of glass all the audio
Engineers complain dude you should
really
you know you cover your dining room in
in tarps that's going to be great for
for my family where I've taken over the
dining room and covered it in tarps
I just
I care about two things here one I care
about inspiring people and two I care
about getting people a future
and
I'm looking at the people I'm trying to
inspire and I'm trying to get a future
for
and they don't even know what risk
they're in and they don't appreciate it
and they turn things into drama because
they're not strong enough to to
withstand like all the voices
of you know like if the Lancet says well
this definitely didn't come from a lab
in Wuhan well who am I I guess the
Lancet said
is it's important to recognize that we
can inspire people
but if I can't even get you to wake up
and I can't even get somebody in the
government
to to understand ideas have consequences
ulam and teller's ideas have great
consequences we are not
Brian I've spent a year
I have more or less told people why I
believe there are three generations of
fermions a year ago
I have not had a single physicist on
planet Earth
say
I want to talk to you about why you say
there are three generations of fermions
I gave a reason why the world appears to
be chiral but actually is not chiral
well it appears that the weak Force beta
decay
knows it's left from its right maximally
violating of season yeah right and
I have not had one person
come to me and say
I want to talk to you about that
um
do you think it's credentialism you're
not in Academia you're seen as an
outsider I get I get literally it's not
me Brian
it's not me it's the field when Peter
White
came out with his idea
um which was to build it around uh the
group su3 which has the strong
communicates the strong force which is
what holds nuclei together when the
protons want to run away from each other
packed in so tightly
um I made sure to read what he wrote and
I called him up and he said yeah
nobody's calling now I don't have to
agree with him but at least understand
what he did do and I wanted to make
absolutely sure that I grasped the
general idea what I'm trying to tell you
is I knew that no one was going to much
call Peter no one is listening to each
other there's almost no one working on
physics
and I I think that that's the real
statement is that the question is gonna
be what did the community say
the community basically isn't doing
physics go to your local uh University's
physics you know high energy Theory
seminar and I challenge you to listen to
a talk
uh and find anything that sounds like
physics in it in general it sounds like
oh we're in Six Dimensions we've got a a
compact simple group
um and we look at the following fields
that nobody's ever seen in human history
we've treated super symmetrically even
though we've never seen supersymmetry
we're not working
[Music]
[Music]